[Music]
a big victory for the gop
in the house this week republican nicole
malliotakis flipping new york's 11th
congressional district red republicans
have flipped
10 seats in the house with eight of them
won by female candidates
the congresswoman-elect nicole
meliotanka joins us now nicole welcome
to the show and congratulations on your
victory
uh first and foremost what do you think
was the chief reason for that victory uh
that is my um you know i grew up in
staten island and i heard from a lot of
people
that it was the defund the police
movement on the left that really
terrified them
look our city is moving more and more to
the left and people are seeing crime
increasing quality life deteriorating
our mayor keeps hammering us over the
head with high taxes so people had
enough of a one-party democratic rule
and this was their opportunity to speak
out and make sure that new york has at
least
one republican representing our city in
washington
tell me about this freedom squad that
you have an idea for
you know we don't have a name yet
because we're not in high school but i
got to tell you that
uh there is a natural alliance that is
occurring here and we are bonded
by the fact that we come from different
experiences
of socialism my mother was a cuban
refugee who fled
the castro regime in 1959 carlos jimenez
is
cuban born he came to the america at the
age of six
we also have victoria spartz who comes
from the ukraine
grew up under soviet union rule and you
also have maria elvira
salazar who is like me the daughter of
cuban refugees and so
uh we have a natural alliance that is
forming and we are bonded by our love of
america
a love for freedom and liberty and the
opportunity that the american dream
represents and we want to preserve that
and we must push back against the forces
who are trying to destroy that
you know one of the challenges that
you're going to face when it comes to
issues related particularly to new york
is this massive
exodus from new york city amid the
coronavirus amid an uptick in crime it's
been pretty astounding if
if you look at these numbers new york
city locals leaving over the past eight
months 295
103 change of address request from march
1st through october 31st 2020.
what do you think about that and what
could be done to rectify that and bring
new york back
and this goes back to the original point
people seeing crime
increasing this wacky bail law that took
effect that led to
sharp increase in murder and shootings
and and
burglaries as well as car thefts people
feel less safe in the community and also
the quality of life is deteriorating
with these massive shutdowns as you know
broadway is shut down and you can't go
to madison square garden and our
restaurants are suffering the stores are
being boarded up because they're afraid
of looters
and so people are generally concerned so
we have to ensure that we
are having a real dialogue with mayor de
blasio and governor cuomo about the
impacts that their shutdowns and
restrictions are having
on our economy and making sure that we
have a balanced approach
to reopening of course public safety is
paramount
but we can't destroy our city and drive
people
out or else we're going to be in a very
very bad situation
come this time next year so for me it's
about providing a counter view
to what the mayor and the governor are
doing and ensuring that we work together
to find common ground to make sure that
we keep our economy open and vibrant and
we can keep new yorkers here because the
middle class has had enough
and they are leaving in droves
yeah we didn't get to it today but
obviously we also have that 10 pm curfew
that's going to be rolling in on
restaurants and other industries maybe
we'll get to that next time but
congratulations on your win and we'll
talk more next time nicole
appreciate it thank you thanks so much